[Musique]
l'egypte y passe tranquillement leur
temps à peindre les arbres et à chanter
des shadoks tant bien que mal se sont
multipliés et partant dahir la terre les
shadoks avait entendu dire que la terre
était ronde alors qu'ils avaient
fabriqué des engins exprès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
mais la tvh ont fait court n'était pas
tellement que ça ou bien dans certains
cas et les tenir mais dans l'autre sens
et ça ne simplifie pas les choses
il n'est pas pure mais il était prudent
parce que il me évidemment il ne savait
pas du tout qu elle déclaré les jbe
lévriers mais il se disait ne nous
cachons pas trop la tête
les ondées venir avec les shadoks ou ne
sait jamais mais qu'ils avançaient
intrépide et un jour il dira l'ennemi
c'était des arbres tout simplement ou
des bouts de cailloux qui dépassait
neige les shadoks étaient pas habitués
ennemis bien sûr ne pourrait pas mais
c'était une ruse évidemment il pensait
alors les j'adore beaucoup plus rusés se
déguisait en ennemis et bouger encore
moins ils attendaient le temps qu'il
fallait et coller une mission attendait
moins le sauté dessus et le faisait
prisonniers le jeu pouvait durer assez
longtemps d'autant plus que dès que les
vaillants shadoks avait le dos tourné
certains ennemis perfide profitait pour
repousser alors les jib y virent qu'ils
y avait encore de beaux jours à passer
sur la terre tant qu'il y aurait des
arbres et des petits cailloux pour tenir
les shadoks occupée
[Musique]
oui